early voting officially started
yesterday but because of those high
winds we saw a lot of people chose to
cast their vote today instead Madison
Kimbrough joins us live from The
Newsroom with what officials and voters
are saying Madison yeah it's been a busy
day for several early voting sites
across the valley according to officials
over 11 000 people cast their ballot on
Saturday according to officials as of 3
pm voter turnout today reached over 5400
people some reported technical issues at
the Deer Springs site yesterday however
officials share with 8 news now that
while there were some concerns the
problem was quickly resolved voters we
spoke to this evening pleased with how
their experience went Sharon why it's
vital for them to cast their ballot
I have grandkids that are coming up and
it's very important to me that they're
able to make a choice
in their lives as for other voting early
sites those include Desert Breeze
Community Center Centennial Center in
the Home Depot parking lot and Meadows
mall and we have a full list of
long-term early voting sites across the
valley on 8newsnow.com a reminder that
early voting lasts through November 4th
with election day being November 8.